Today we'll be speaking with doctor heady Cobar on craving and mindfulness,
Dr. Cobras and assistant professor in the Department of Psychiatry at the Yale
University School of Medicine as well as the director of the clinical and
affective neuroscience lab and director of research at the Yale therapeutic
neuroscience clinic.
Doctor Cobras interest,
um,
are focused on using a multilevel approach to understand the use of cognitive
strategies to regulate emotion.
She's used both behavioral and neuro imaging tools to better understand the
psychological and biological mechanisms that underlie processes related to
emotion craving,
the cog cognitive regulation of emotion and craving in both healthy adults as
well as psychiatric populations.
Dr Cobra has received several honors including the National Institute of Drug
Abuse Women and Gender Travel Award,
the National Institute of Drug Abuse,
early career investigator travel award and the Yale Center for Clinical
Investigation Scholar Award.
Her work has also been mentioned in the popular media,
including outlets such as CNN,
ABC News,
La Times,
and US news and world report.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Heady Cobar.
So one of the things that I wanted to start out by asking you,
it's just a little bit about your journey into the world of emotion as it
relates to the craving and mindfulness.
Really kind of what got me interested in this in the first place.
Uh,
my graduate advisor at Columbia used to say that there's no such thing as
research.
It's all me search.
So everybody ends up starting their own kind of concerns and I certainly have
emotions.
So that's definitely one good point of entry.
Um,
but I think more than that I'm,
I crave a lot of things.
And I think,
uh,
since when I was very little girl,
wanting more of stuff was a very prominent in my experience.
And,
uh,
that is certainly one part of the equation.
So having feelings and wanting things.
Yeah,
some of the basic blocks of human,
you know,
life.
Exactly.
And,
and,
and the fact that,
you know,
to be a productive adult in society,
you need to know how to regulate all of these emotions and craving as they come
up.
You can't just make,
you know,
the rolling stones said it very,
very well.
You can't always get what you want to learn how to deal with it.
I mean,
what's really neat and I agree,
the research to me search,
I mean in many ways that makes so much sense and it's what gets us,
gets us inspired to study the things that we devote our life towards.
Right?
And so you had this early interest in craving and,
and feeling.
And since then,
I mean you've really established an amazing research program for the second all
of these things and very cone.
Yeah.
Well I want to ask you a little bit about,
cause I think it's really exciting.
Um,
and I think a lot of people out there,
I'd love to hear you share your thoughts on it.
So I mean you've really delved into the scientific study of craving,
right?
And you've really looked at this phenomena,
you know,
uh,
that we experience in everyday life and that can range from craving food to you
looked at craving for cigarettes.
And I wondered if you could first just say a bit about what you think craving is
in the first,
and then does it differ when we're craving like a really awesome piece of,
you know,
cake versus like craving a cigarette if were a smoker?
That's a really good question.
So craving is,
first of all,
I certainly defined at least part of it as an emotion,
but I think,
uh,
in the world of the people who study craving,
people usually think about it as a construct that has a few different pieces to
it.
One part is definitely the affect,
the emotion,
that feeling of wanting that almost anybody can identify,
right?
Like late at night,
you're just like,
ah,
your body maybe gets a little contracted and you want something.
Um,
maybe when you see a commercial on TV,
right?
And there's like this really nice ice cream and you're just,
oh,
that looks so good.
So that's a part of feeling.
Uh,
but with that,
there's also a cognitive component.
So the thoughts that go along with it,
if I have this ice cream,
I'm gonna feel better.
If I don't have it,
I'm going to feel worse.
It's going to be really good.
So you have expectancies about it.
Um,
but I think one of the most important parts is the motivational part,
which is the impetus to kind of act on these thoughts and feelings and get up
and actually go and do it.
And when we think about craving,
uh,
scientifically we need to understand all three parts,
although some of them might be easier to measure than others.
Um,
then you were sort of alluding to the fact that it may or may not be similar to
crave something like an awesome piece of cake relative to,
you know,
maybe a drug user who wants to,
um,
you know,
smoke crack.
Um,
and,
uh,
we've now run these kinds of experiments with,
um,
individuals who smoke cigarettes,
who,
you know,
normal individuals who eat food.
We're now working with individuals who are morbidly obese,
um,
showing them kind of pictures of food and measuring their craving.
We've worked with crack cocaine users,
uh,
who are also sometimes heroin users.
So there's really an individuals who abuse,
um,
methamphetamines or crystal meth.
And so we really are looking at it across different kinds of modalities and
different kinds of items that people might crave.
And we find two things.
The first is that to some degree,
uh,
even within the same individual craving for food,
for example,
for a cigarette smoker and craving cigarettes,
uh,
feels the same to them and typically the differences a matter of degree.
So they just crave the cigarettes and much more intensely typically.
Um,
the second thing is when we look at brain activity,
um,
it looks like both kinds of craving really tap into the same neural systems.
Are the same neural systems instantiate the same craving for food and the
craving for a cigarette?
And again,
maybe it's a matter of degree.
Um,
the thing that's also interesting is we recently tried to summarize all the data
across all the studies of craving,
uh,
specifically,
um,
imaging.
So fmri studies of craving across this is now 50 something studies between let's
say 1996 and 2010.
And it looks like,
and this is for drugs and it looks like across all the different drugs,
there are some regions that are really common.
So some regions that craving for heroin and a heroin user craving for cigarettes
and a cigarette smoker craving for um,
uh,
you know,
cocaine and a cocaine user.
They all overlap.
We haven't done that study yet,
but maybe,
um,
so all of them,
they really recruit some shared set of,
of,
uh,
of regions in the brain.
But there are also some regions that are unique.
And I think that one of the challenges that we're going to have is try to
understand why is it that some regions are the same and those are probably
regions that are associated with learning and regions that are associated with,
uh,
kind of the experience of reward that people get from these things.
Um,
and then some regions that are distinct and what are those about and what,
what do they contribute to,
let's say cigarette craving separately from food craving.
And we don't know the answers to that yet.
See,
I mean,
what's really neat about this is you've not only taken kind of a qualitative
approach,
but you've really gone in and looked at the neural mechanisms.
Um,
you're talking about the work that you've done in this,
you know,
broader kind of Meta analysis across numerous studies and what,
what are these brand new agents that are common across different types of,
you know,
craved substances or foods or,
different,
different kinds of things.
Do we know at this point what those regions are?
So one region that seems to come up again and again across different studies of
craving,
both in our data in and this met analysis that really is kind of consistently
active during craving across many,
many different studies,
many,
many different kinds of drugs is the ventral striatum and the ventral striatum
is a region.
Um,
it's,
uh,
kind of in the inner part of the brain.
So it's not in the Cortex,
not in the kind of newer part of the brain.
Um,
so,
and it means that it's a part that's kind of fairly conserved from animals and
animals have it and we have it.
And we see it also in animal studies when they kind of pursue drugs.
Um,
and when they pursue food,
uh,
we see that it's also involved in that.
And we think that part of the reason why it's involved in craving is because it
expresses,
um,
that part of the learning.
Like,
we know that this is going to be good.
We want that because we've had experience with before.
Uh,
you've probably noticed even in your own life that you rarely crave things that
you've never tried.
All right?
Like you might be curious about them,
but typically the things that we really kind of come to want or things that we
had before and were really awesome.
And so the idea is that,
um,
with time we learned that these things are really good and that part of that
learning is expressed through some function in the ventral striatum and some we
think,
uh,
through the action of a neurotransmitter called dopamine.
Um,
another region that is typically involved is the orbital frontal cortex.
And people have argued that what it does is really,
um,
compute maybe,
uh,
the value of this item to us.
The thing that's really interesting is that we see these regions and people
crave,
let's say chocolate or they crave drugs.
But the way that we get them to crave it as we show them pictures either of
let's say for cigarette smokers,
we show them pictures of cigarettes or other people smoking.
Um,
and for food we do the same thing that is at the heart of food commercials,
right?
It's like you see the picture of the ice cream and you go,
ah,
I want that.
I want to put that in my mouth right now.
And so this is how we do it.
And so would that suggest,
is that craving really arises even at the prospect of having it?
Like we learned that seeing ice cream is related to ice cream.
Um,
and that's again,
potentially a reason why some of these regions get activated.
I mean,
it's interesting and I know sometimes in some of the conversations that you'd
have before,
you know,
you can think about sometimes how craving goes too far and we need to find ways
to sort of harness or,
or reign it in.
And so another line of Europe has really looked at the regulation of,
of craving,
um,
and the neural mechanisms that may underlie our ability to sort of reign in
those cravings and bring them to levels that are more sort of adaptive for us in
our everyday life.
And I'm just curious,
you could say a little bit about your work there and to what extent is trying to
regulate craving different from some of the work we know that's out there that
looks at how we try to control or you know,
harness just feeling states like feeling happy or sad or angry.
Is it something really different when it comes to cravings?
That's a really good question.
So I think that in general I anchor thinking about regulation of craving and a
greater construct of self control.
So being able to control your thoughts,
your feelings,
your behavior,
all of these,
I think,
uh,
or probably part of a,
a larger ability that probably has maybe some parts.
Um,
and under regulating emotion there's negative emotion like sadness,
anger,
you know,
other disgust.
And then there's the appetitive are more positive emotions,
like craving being one of them.
Um,
however often the intuitive sense that people have when they think about self
control are regulating themselves and delaying gratification.
It's in the context of these things that we want that are not really good for
us.
Right?
Like the classic examples are always,
you know,
are you going to have the cookie now or two cookies later from the Walter
Michelle experiments?
Um,
right.
and uh,
and so I think that first of all,
it is important to anchor regulation of craving is one part of this,
but it's almost like the canonical kind,
right?
Um,
the canonical kind of self control.
In my research,
what we've tried to,
to show,
uh,
well there are a few things,
but one thing that we tried to show is that,
um,
uh,
there are a kind of parts of the brain that we know are involved in self control
more generally.
Um,
and one suggestion has been for people who are studying addiction,
uh,
that people who let's say are cigarette smokers,
they're just unable to recruit these brain regions and regulate their craving,
that it's just completely uncontrollable.
And cigarette smokers,
there's just one example of people who say it's really,
really hard for them to quit.
And the data actually suggests that it's very,
very hard to quit.
But you know,
uh,
certainly there's a,
in the media,
this idea of like,
um,
crystal meth users as being these crazy fans who can't stop.
And,
you know,
certainly crack cocaine had its heyday of beating considered to be this crazy
drug that people use.
Um,
and we really wanted to know,
can they really regulate their craving?
We had this clinical data that suggested that when they undergo,
um,
you know,
eight or six weeks of,
uh,
16 weeks of,
cognitive behavioral treatment,
more prolonged treatment that has a component on regulation of craving,
that something changes,
that they learn some skills and then they're better able to stop their drug use.
And we also had this idea that this occurs to some kind of biological mechanism.
You know,
and um,
so we,
we looked at the brain and we,
we looked at,
we recruited first and our first set of studies,
a cigarette smokers.
But we've now done this with,
um,
for example,
crack cocaine users.
And we trained them to use very simple strategies to regulate their craving.
And so I'm the kind of first and most basic strategy that we tried is to ask
them to look,
let's say it's someone else smoking when they feel craving or look at this kind
of luscious chocolate cake and just think to themselves,
what are all the reasons that I have not to eat this cake right now or not to
smoke this cigarette?
What are the negative consequences that could arise if I actually engaged in
this behavior?
And what we found,
um,
first is that when people did this,
they reported much less craving.
So they were really able to,
um,
and,
and the same with crack cocaine.
Even when they were feeling the craving.
They really want it to smoke their crack.
Um,
if they really thought about the longterm consequences in that moment,
whoa.
They suddenly said,
you know what?
I actually,
you know,
I don't crave it a five.
I created a three.
Um,
the second thing that we were able to show is that they were able to recruit
these brain regions and systems really that are involved in self control in
general and an emotion regulation in general,
but in the context of regulating craving when they recruited,
uh,
when were,
they showed greater activity in these regions including let's say the
Dorsolateral prefrontal Cortex,
which is the parts of the brain that are right here.
Um,
they also showed reduced activity in these regions that we know are involved in
craving.
So they were actually able to not only manipulate how they were feeling,
but also manipulate the way that their brain works so that it was,
um,
showing a,
a reduced neural activity in these regions that give rise to craving.
Gosh,
that's so fascinating.
And I know you've taken this work to look at regulation of craving towards a
strategy that I know is something near and dear to your heart,
which is mindfulness.
And it's really interesting to think about the powerful role of mindfulness that
it can play,
not just in sort of everyday life.
Um,
you know,
instances,
people think about decreasing stress or worry that can also help us manage our
craving.
And so I wonder if you could first maybe tell us a bit about what mindfulness is
for those who don't know.
Um,
and also some of the promise you think and your work is showing that it might
actually help us manage cravings and you know,
Gosh,
like our abuse of substances as well.
Something that,
like you said,
is so hard to control.
So what is mindfulness?
So mindfulness,
uh,
one of the classic ways to define it as,
as a two component construct,
the first is a component of attention.
So your attention is directed as a state to the present moment.
Whatever is happening right now.
So,
um,
for example,
to the feeling of your back on the chair,
your feeling of your,
uh,
kind of the weight coming down on the chair,
maybe your foot on the floor,
you can wiggle your toes and try to feel what that feels like.
So really an attention that's kind of concentrated on whatever the present
moment experience,
uh,
is.
And the second part is the attitude that you have as you're paying attention.
And that attitude is kind of curious and open and accepting.
Um,
and it's kind of like asking yourself the question,
can you be okay with this?
Whatever it is,
can you just be okay with us?
Can you let this be whatever it is?
And of course,
often people hear this and they say,
well,
you know,
sometimes like horrible things happen in the world and it's true,
but the question is,
does it ever help to really get upset about it?
Right?
Um,
and so really it's just a,
an attitude that tries to be to let things be exactly as they are.
Um,
and the result of this is typically a reduced reactivity.
And some people think of this as like the third component of not reacting to
whatever it is in the context of,
uh,
of craving.
The way that we've looked at this,
um,
is really in a few different directions.
One is in the context of regulating craving in the moment.
So,
uh,
again,
in these experiments we show people,
let's say pictures of food or pictures of cigarettes.
We,
uh,
we,
you know,
they feel craving for these things.
And then we say,
can you just let the feeling be,
can you notice that it's happening?
But just see if you can be okay with it exactly as it is.
Um,
so they're not thinking about the longterm negative consequences are really
doing something different.
Almost like taking a step back and just seeing if it can,
uh,
let it be because,
one of the findings that have already been out there is that craving and a lot
of emotions in general been like a wave.
So they start and they rise and the reach some kind of peak.
But even if you don't really do anything,
they kind of calm down naturally.
And so one part is knowing that and just letting it be and maybe see if it kind
of comes down.
Actually.
Um,
what we found now in a few studies is that I'm doing this,
assuming this kind of stance in the moment,
um,
is really associated with reduced craving.
So it doesn't work exactly the same for everybody.
Some people really need much more training than just the short training that we
give him that given these experiments.
But for a lot of people just knowing that they can just be okay with it and not
really engage and not really a kind of,
not really go into the craving and not really push it away.
Just being with it actually helps them feel less craving.
Um,
in a,
in a study,
in a collaboration with,
um,
some of my colleagues at University of Pittsburgh and Carnegie Mellon,
we've also shown that when individuals do this,
again in a,
in a context of an FMRI experiment,
they all show also show reduced activity in these brain regions that we know are
associated with craving.
So just kind of assuming that,
um,
attitude,
uh,
in the moment is really associated with both reduced reports and reduced brain
activity that's associated with craving.
But what we've also done by now is that we've looked at treatment studies for
individuals who are cigarette smokers and,
um,
uh,
in the,
in this treatment study,
and this is in collaboration with some people here at Yale,
uh,
individuals,
were either assigned to randomly assigned to a treatment that was based on
mindfulness or a treatment that was based on kind of cognitive behavioral
principles.
And they learn to do this over eight,
eight,
eight meetings over four weeks.
And what we found is that individuals who learned how to kind of use these
mindful space strategies in the context of quitting smoking,
we're actually a really quite successful,
even more successful,
uh,
in our hands at least then the other,
um,
treatment,
uh,
in reducing their smoking.
Well,
we also showed when we looked at their brain activity,
um,
after the treatment and we stress them out in the scanner.
So one of the things that are amazing about my cluster,
other people have shown is that,
um,
training in mindfulness over time,
so not just in the moment but really over time,
over sometimes for eight weeks,
uh,
is associated with reduced stress,
reduced anxiety,
um,
reduced depression.
There's now studies that show that it's good for chronic pain.
So it helps people with a lot of,
kind of both psychological and physical conditions.
Um,
in our study we stress people out.
We really want it to,
if they were less stressed after learning a mindfulness meditation,
um,
and it turned out that yes,
they were less stressed and they showed reduced brain activity in a region we
call Amygdala,
which is,
um,
well people argue about what it might mean,
but it certainly is associated with kind of tagging things in your environment
as potentially dangerous or,
um,
as requiring kind of extra tension being salient and important.
And these individuals,
even during stress showed reduced activity in that region.
And what was more is that those individuals who showed the least activity in
that region,
we're the ones who were best at quitting or kind of smoke the,
the least amount of cigarettes even,
uh,
two months out.
And so that suggests that one of the things that,
um,
that it does except for reducing cravings,
also reducing people's individual experiences of stress and because stress,
sometimes it induces craving.
All of these things come together.
Beautiful Data and exciting directions you're going in right now.
Thank you.
And as you think about some of these directions that your work is headed in and
you sort of broadened the scope out to think about,
you know,
sort of the,
the future as a whole,
sort of,
where do you see it headed?
Kind of where,
where is this work going?
The emotion in general or my work or
wherever you want to go.
Well,
I think for emotion,
one of the things that are,
um,
I'm excited about the kind of unfolding debate of,
uh,
our emotions constructed.
What are they,
how are they constructed,
both in terms of experience and in the brain.
Um,
some people are still arguing that there is such things as basic emotions that
everybody experiences.
And,
uh,
I certainly have an,
an educated opinion and this discussion and I'm looking forward to see where it
unfolds.
I think in the context of craving,
um,
we're really,
uh,
the challenges to face kind of some of the most serious,
public health problems that we have using this kind of knowledge.
So,
um,
substance use disorders are some of the most prevalent,
psychiatric disorders that we have,
right?
And so,
um,
I think now it's 37% of people will at some point in their lives qualify for
this kind of diagnosis,
um,
in America.
And it's,
it's really quite serious.
And so first of all,
um,
using the insight that we have to do a few things.
First of all,
with the knowledge that there is a biological way that kind of our psychological
stance can reduce craving.
Um,
we can convince,
um,
uh,
people like the institute,
the National Institute of drug abuse to give us money to study these,
um,
biological mechanisms of psychological treatments for substance use disorders.
Another way that I,
that I think about it is that we can kind of ahead of time,
use both the um,
uh,
both parts,
both the people self report of how good strategies are for them and their brain
data to maybe predict,
uh,
which treatment is better for them.
So one of the things that we're trying to see is if I bring you into my lab and
I teach you let's say three strategies to control your craving for chocolate
and a,
and let's say what you're really,
really easily,
uh,
managing with one strategy and the other one,
it's not so effective for you.
If I really train you on this strategy that works for you really,
really well,
is that going to help you quit your chocolate habit that much more?
Um,
and so really try to see if we can kind of diagnose people ahead of time and
then help them out,
uh,
to get better treatment using that knowledge.
Um,
and also of course to understand with treatment,
and we have some pilot data on this already.
Um,
how much training do they really need?
So we have now data that suggests that even half an hour of training just in
regulation of craving helps people quit smoking,
smoking.
So people are even two weeks after they come to our lab,
they're smoking last if we train them in a,
in a,
in one of these strategies.
And so,
uh,
now we're trying to kind of vary the dose can be really just give them,
you know,
let's say a few days of training and really help them quit smoking and how much
more training do you need?
Um,
and this is a little bit different than putting them through,
you know,
like one of those really much longer treatments.
Um,
another way to think about it is that we are trying to understand when people
undergo this training or undergo even kind of longer treatments and they get
better at the end and they actually succeed,
what is it about their brain that changes?
Um,
and we have some data that suggests already that people who undergo cognitive
behavioral treatment for this study was with cocaine users.
They actually show that the parts of their brain,
like the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex becomes more efficient.
So it actually becomes less active during a cracking of control task at the end
of treatment compared to before.
And so how much more efficient can we make the brain and in kind of enacting
these acts of control,
those are some of the questions that I'd like to continue asking in this context
at least.
And so when you think about continuing to ask these questions,
and a lot of these questions will be answered by you,
but also students,
you know,
we're going to be a big part of the future of where this field is headed.
You know,
what,
what kinds of advice do you usually give to students are asking you,
you know,
should I embark in this field of emotion?
What about craving?
What do you,
what do you tell them?
Oh,
wow.
Um,
so I don't think anybody's ever asked me that quite so directly.
but if anybody did,
I would certainly say that they need to study what they care about.
I find that for me,
um,
I think in academia in general,
people work very hard,
maybe here at Yale even extra more.
But,
um,
but I think that part of what fuels it for me is my personal curiosity and my
commitment to making the world a better place and helping people who are
suffering and people who have substance use disorders are suffering and,
and even people who eat too much.
Right?
So one of the other epidemics that are plaguing our society is obesity.
And if we can use some of the insights that we are garnering from learning about
regulation of craving,
uh,
in the context of drug users to help individuals who are obese,
who potentially have overeating issues,
um,
and even maybe people who are not obese,
who have over eating issues.
And that's most people I know.
Um,
I think that would be exciting.
And so trying to,
um,
follow your heart and do you care about,
because answering the questions that you think need answering is usually what
gets you out of bed in the morning.
All excited.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I think that in general,
I read a paper recently by James Gross,
who I love,
um,
and he specifically was talking the future of research on emotion regulation.
He said,
the future is so bright,
you have to wear shades.
I think that's a,
that's a good,
a good note.
Well,
thank you so much for speaking today.
Heddy thank you,
Jean,
for having me.
So this concludes our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Heady Cobra from
Yale University.
Thanks again,
Heidi.